(upbeat music)
- All science careers involve creativity.
Think about it.
We're asking and answering questions,
and we're solving the world's problems.
So the more creatively we can
solve the world's problems,
the more new ideas and concepts
and approaches we can use to
address the world's problems,
the better off we'll be.
- Creativity is the guiding force
on the path to good science.
So there isn't a science job out there
that doesn't benefit from creativity.
Like you can be an engineer,
building more efficient
transistors for tinier
and tinier phones.
You could be a climate scientist,
figuring out how we can
reduce our carbon footprint
and save the world from
climate catastrophe,
or an agricultural researcher.
Reducing efficient ways
to feed the planet.
Or maybe an entomologist like me.
Understanding how
relationships between organisms
keep us all healthy.
Creativity is important
in all of these careers.
- One really cool job is,
is working for a science museum.
And so the people who are like the
the chief directors or bioscientist,
or what have you for science
museums usually have a biology
or a science background of some kind,
maybe you've have gone
through even being a PhD
or postdoctoral fellow.
And their job is to design exhibits for,
for visitors to museums
and come up with engaging ways
to share ideas in science.
And so I see that's a really cool job
that you might not immediately think of.
(upbeat music)